well what are some important currencies
that you try to get I know there's the
milk scene I know there's the fear topic
you know there is the patient side word
you're saying 51 days is you know the
the Waco Siege 120 days was the one with
Japan 85 days Montana siege what are
some currencies you used to have
leverage when you negotiate with the
hostage I think the biggest goal that
you try to retrieve is a level of trust
people will not surrender they won't
cooperate they won't agree to something
unless they have a certain level of
trust now it takes a little bit of time
to build that and there's various levels
of trust but that's what we're really
striving for the other thing I should
say based on your question we really
have to look at what negotiators do in
kind of two categories one is an actual
hostage taking and you have to
understand this is more like business
because in a hostage taking the person
has a clear-cut goal in mind they want
something they can't get on their own
maybe it's escape maybe it's money maybe
it's a release from prison whatever it
might be they can't do it on their own
so they hold the hostage and threaten to
harm the hostage unless the authorities
give them what they want the good news
on that story is they need us the police
to do what they want so it sets up a
scenario for quid pro quo bargaining
well we can do this but you have to do
that and if you keep in mind that the
person is there primarily to get their
demands met and not to kill that gives
us a powerful advantage and usually with
the passage of time they hold the
hostage they feel initially empowered
and in control and then when time passes
and they don't get us to jump every time
they snap your fingers and we don't roll
over and give them everything they want
without them giving us something
yeah they finally come to the point of
view saying well I guess I'm not gonna
get what I want you know there's an old
story about a hijacking in New York you
know way back in the 70s and the guy
wanted to fly to Europe and in part of
his discussions with the negotiators he
said I want next time you come out here
bring me a hot cup of coffee with cream
and two
Sugar's you know an hour later the
coffee comes out then it's cold and
there's no sugar and there's no cream
and the guy surrenders about 20 minutes
later and they said well what was it
that made you surrendered he said well I
figured if I couldn't get a decent cup
of coffee this other stuff wasn't gonna
work out you know and it and it's sort
of a humorous way to look at kind of how
the expectations got lowered and the
reality set in that hey you're not the
Big Kahuna you don't just say you want
something and it's gonna happen you got
to go through us now those incidents
that I just described it's only about
ten percent really of what we do most
police officers will never work a
legitimate hostage situation what
they're working 90 percent is
emotionally driven situations where the
victim not really a hostage the victim
and the person holding them you know
have a pre-existing relationship it's an
employee employer it's a
boyfriend/girlfriend husband/wife you
know neighbor neighbor whatever it might
be they have a history that is tense
problematic and confrontational that has
erupted into this event and those are
the cases where the person really
doesn't know how to get out of what they
got into they just aren't expressing
their emotions and our job in those
cases is not so much to make a deal but
to lower their emotional levels get them
to a point where they're thinking a
little more clearly a little more
rationally and realizing that anything
violent they they do is just
self-defeating and self-destructive and
we're pretty successful at those as well
but I will tell you when there is loss
of life it's in those situations not a
hostage situation
interesting
you
[Music]